a new safety study recommends tougher
standards for companies that make those
inclined sleepers for infants it follows
a series of deadly incidents the
government says that 59 babies have died
in the sleeper since 2005 several
companies including fisher-price
voluntarily recalled them earlier this
year our consumer investigative
correspondent Andrew Warner has been
covering this story from the beginning
Anna but what prompted this latest new
study well Gail the Consumer Product
Safety Commission says it needed to know
exactly what was causing those infant
deaths it asked independent experts to
do a study it turns out that study
agrees with what parents of children who
died have long maintained that the
products are too dangerous for infants
to sleep in we spoke to some of those
parents back in August two months and
ten days old these parents spoke to us
in August just months after their
infants died in fisher-price rock and
play in Klein sleepers I would like to
raise awareness there's people out here
that are still using the rock and play
sleeper that our children got in Haley
and Ty Hampton son Liam was 13 weeks old
he was a little baby a little cold about
you they're a little cuddle buddy huh
Jonathan and Amanda Butler's daughter
Aria was just 10 weeks old she was
everything to me they're just 2 of 59
babies the Consumer Product Safety
Commission says died in Incline sleepers
since 2005
millions were purchased nationwide we
were at the instructions we don't were
supposed to do and still my son isn't
here today I mean it says on the box
safe for all night sleep we didn't think
that there could be anything out there
like that that could say that it was
safe for your child to sleep in all
night if that wasn't the case but a new
report finds in Klein sleepers are too
risky none of them we feel are safe for
infant sleep scientist Aaron Manon led
the study commissioned by the CPSC she
and her team examined baby's movements
in several sleepers and found
problematic design babies are dying and
have died in these products and I think
that
based on the results of our research
it's something that has to do with the
design of a product pediatric experts
say babies are supposed to sleep flat on
their backs but one key problem with
infant sleepers they're angled position
as high as 30 degrees pediatrician dr.
Ben Hoffman
first of all knowing what we know about
babies relatively large heads relatively
weak knacks the upright positioning can
lead to the head flopping forward and
that can block the airway which is
devastating to babies and they can't
pick their head back up correct
the CPSC now plans to recommend a
tougher standard for sleepers but these
parents say that's no comfort I don't
want another family go through this
because it it's turned our life upside
down to the pardon the CPSC's new
standard would lower the allowed angle
of those sleepers the Commission is
expected to vote on that proposal next
week it will then be open for comments
we reached out to manufacturers for
response but we did not hear back you
know I've always thought they were great
baby gifts I've given a couple in the
past they weren't the fisher-price the
the fisher-price recall so what should
people do who have a version of it or if
you have one you need to get rid of it
the progress of the the maker well so we
the question is the incline of the
product you know if you have a baby some
type of product and you have the baby in
that product you need to watch the baby
make sure the baby is not falling asleep
in that product and if they are get them
to a flat sleeping position as soon as
possible is what the xmin would you say
when you say get rid of it you don't
mean give it to a friend you mean no no
really like you should be either
returning it to the company if it's
under recall if you can and if not don't
just hand it off to somebody else
during the parents that have them really
like the maybe were former chairman of
the CPSC said that to to us last time
she said you know the problem is parents
really love this product and many of
them even defend the product the problem
is you don't know which baby it's going
to be yeah I know we have a
six-month-old at home we had one week
well then we got rid of it and we used a
baby box Google baby box it sounds crazy
all they need is a cardboard box with a
flat mattress you they will nappin
yeah flat and nothing around them
nothing yeah Anna thank you very much
[ __ ] it